welcome back to las vegas now in around
healthcare the sponsors of this next
segment wants to remind adults
especially our elderly that vaccines are
not just for kids so we spoke to a
doctor to learn more
[Music]
hi my name is denita calra i'm a family
physician for intermountain healthcare
today we're at our green valley a my
generation clinic and what we do here is
we help take care of our adults and
senior population today we're going to
talk about why vaccines are important
not only for our children but for adults
in general there are some conditions
that we need to re-vaccinate for or
vaccinate originally for because as we
get older our conditions and our
diseases change and everything is
sounding very good today there are four
suggested vaccines adults should stay up
to date on
pneumococcal hepatitis b
zoster and influenza let's start with
the pneumococcal vaccine a new
pneumococcal vaccine has been released
for people aged 65 and older who haven't
been vaccinated or under 65 and immune
compromised or with a chronic condition
that puts them at risk of pneumonia such
as asthma and smoking
the pneumococcal vaccine can prevent
some cases of pneumonia meningitis and
sepsis i strongly recommend pneumococcal
vaccine especially in our environment
because of the strong changes in our
temperature including dust winds and all
the allergens in the air now let's move
on to hepatitis b hepatitis b vaccine is
recommended for all adults just like it
is for all kids
this vaccine protects against liver
cancer and liver disease two-thirds of
those who get hepatitis b don't have a
known risk factor for it but it can
develop a serous infection if not
protected the zoster shingles vaccine is
recommended for people 50 years and
older
shingles is a viral infection that
causes a painful rash
anyone who has had chickenpox may
develop shingles if you have certain
health conditions that make you immune
compromised it may be recommended
starting at the age of 19. and of course
the influenza vaccine the seasonal
influenza vaccine is recommended to
everyone age six months and older and it
generally starts early fall some people
feel that if they got the influenza
vaccine once they don't have to get it
again but it is very important to get it
every year for the virus can change and
besides those four very important
vaccines we still need to keep covet in
mind new versions of this vaccine are
coming soon a recombinant protein
vaccine by nova vaxx may be available
for those who haven't been vaccinated
yet and for those who have been
vaccinated boosters targeting more
recent variants are being studied and
just a reminder many vaccines are
covered by your health insurance here at
intermountain healthcare we're happy to
set up a preventative visit to help you
decide which vaccines are good for you
[Music]
thank you to intermountain healthcare
for sponsoring that segment for more
just head to intermountainhealthcare.org
nevada